le 15 avril 2019 la cathédrale notre
dame de paris bâti huit cent cinquante
ans plus tôt perdre et sa flèche sa
toiture son horloge une partie de sa
voûte la destruction partielle de ce
symbole de la france ravagé par les
flammes avaient suscité une vive émotion
dans le monde entier
dès lors les enquêteurs de la brigade
criminelle avaient pour mission de
retrouver des indices dans les décombres
compte tenu de la fragilité de l'édifice
il avait même dû être formés par des
cordistes pour pouvoir effectuer des
prélèvements au dessus des voûtes et
puis est arrivé l'épidémie de colis de
19 qui a ralenti l'enquète qui n'a
finalement repris qu'en novembre dernier
mais deux ans après l' incendie peu
d'éléments filtre sur l'avancée de
l'enquêté néanmoins on sait qu'une
centaine de témoins ont été entendus
lors de l' enquête préliminaire lancée
par le parquet de paris alors accident
ou acte criminel
le 11 février 2020 le procureur de paris
a donné un élément de réponse à ce stade
aujourd'hui nous restons sur l'hypothèse
qui a fait l'objet d'une communication
l'hypothèse accidentelle nous n'excluons
jamais rien dans une enquête mais ce que
l'on peut dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau aujourd'hui qui
accréditerait une hypothèse criminelle
un an après cette déclaration rien ne
semble suggérer davantage la piste
criminelle les enquêteurs semblent
privilégier la piste d'un court circuit
ou celle d'un mégot l'essai et par les
ouvriers qui montait un échafaudage sur
la flèche du monument en parallèle
plusieurs défaillances dans la sécurité
de la cathédrale ont été identifiés
notamment en mauvais entretien des
installations électriques le dispositif
d'alarmé de l'édifice défectueux l'appel
tardif au conflit en raison d'une erreur
d'interprétation de la larme ou encore
un dysfonctionnement du système
électrique d'un des ascenseurs et des
failles qui ne seraient pas à l'origine
de l'incendié mais qui aurait laissé aux
flammes
le temps de se propager dans tout
l'édifice les analyses des prélèvements
sont attendues dans les mois à venir
elle pourrait apporter de nouveaux
éléments de réponse
on se souvient de meylan internationale
après le sinistre près de 830 millions
d'euros avaient été récoltés des fonds
qui avaient fait polémique
l année dernière la cour des comptes
avait ainsi pointé du doigt
l'utilisation des dons par
l'établissement public chargé de la
restauration notre dame des doms censé
être exclusivement dépensés pour les
travaux de réparation et mais qui aurait
servi à payer les salaires du personnel
de la cathédrale ou encore le loyer de
l'établissement public pour la
restauration une utilisation des dons
est désapprouvée par la cour des comptes
le problème est qu'il y à une
débudgétisation c'est à dire que
normalement un établissement public de
ce type doit être financé sur des fonds
publics
or là c'est l'argent des donateurs qui
est utilisé et ses donateurs envisage
ces dons uniquement pour la restauration
de la cathédrale
non pas pour la valorisation d abord la
communication ou le fonctionnement de
cet établissement public
le chantier de la restauration a déjà
commencé il vous sera peut-être possible
de visiter à nouveau notre dame de paris
dès avril 2024